omicron i say that right yes i'm across
omicron covid variant this is variant
number god knows what
uh i think omicron is the 15th greek
letter in the alphabet i have no idea
but they've skipped a few they skipped z
the one that was x i z g chi c i'm
terrible greek letters guys don't quote
me on this um
they skipped that because i don't think
it'd be good i think i mean there's
rational reasons i think um
anyway they skipped a few yeah i don't
know if it's the 15th variant yeah i
don't know um new york city is now
requiring they're strongly recommending
to wear masks indoors in public places
which sucks um
i want to ask you andrew
do you think this thing is ever going
away
there's going to be
a push and pull
between humans and
the coronavirus variants
out into the foreseeable future
and i would measure that future in
months and years
so anyone who
imagined that hopefully we'd be done
with this thing
there are a number of reasons why we
will not be done with this thing the
most obvious are
that one there's a significant body of
humans around the world that are not
vaccinated and they're they're ample
places for this to mutate
number two is that the world is now
interconnected so guess what i'm sure
omicron's already alive and well in the
united states sure i mean i think canada
just reported a
case i mean the odds that is being
contained to where it was reported we're
recording this monday this airs thursday
uh there'll definitely be a case by then
right yeah that would probably be a case
by the time it starts yeah and then um
there's also like a a critical mass of
unvaccinated people here in in the us uh
and so you put all this together and the
odds of this coming here to the u.s and
being a significant factor are very very
high
and oh by the way if it's not omicron
it'll be the next one greek letter after
that the greek letter after that
um so
what we should be doing in in my mind is
uh
accepting that this is the new way of
things and the new reality uh and then
try to mitigate and but live our lives
but by the way we shouldn't let it
obsess us we shouldn't let it let it
keep us from living our lives uh you
know that like there there's there's a
risk reward ratio to everything
and the just the risk is going to be
with us for a while um but we should not
try and say to ourselves that like the
risk is
uh total to a point where it completely
changes our behaviors or our
relationships
ah it's um
well the other thing just add on that is
that
even if you are vaccinated people are
still you're still getting it and some
people are still dying from the bad the
vax is doing good but it's not it's not
it's not full proof at least right now
right yeah i mean that's what the
concern is about omicron is that it's
got a bunch of mutations that would make
it likely to infect someone who has
certain antibodies based upon
existing vaccines now you can have an
omicron specific vaccine that gets
developed and then
that would be more helpful
so that's what they're going to work on
right now
and
we can look forward to all going out and
getting that vaccine incidentally if
you're listening to this
i think that vaccines are a great idea
and if you're still
uh not vaccinated um please do strongly
consider doing so because it'll protect
you
uh hey you might even make out well in
the sense that maybe you'll get like the
cool new omicron
or you'll you'll get some vaccines that
are you know like a little bit more
um developed or with it who knows but
you know i think vaccines are a good uh
a good counter measure just for your
personal safety and
health
so i was looking at the the graph this
is the new york times take that really
well but the graph of case new cases of
coven since since it started let's call
it march 2nd of 2020.
do you know when the peak of covet cases
were
uh
probably early last year it was early it
was late 2020 and then the actual peak
is january 9th 2021 early this year um
so it wasn't in march what i thought was
that that was the spike the actual spike
at least according this like if you just
google covet cases and what they're from
the new york times
it seemed like such an outbreak and it
was because we were not prepared for it
um
but we still and then the second we
still are getting a ton of cases post
vaccine and post uh i guess this isn't
post vaccine but um in the winter months
and then the second peak was actually
this summer um
of this year of 2021 uh in august in
early september um
so covet's still real i think it's
frustrating i think it's frustrating for
all of us so that this is the nuance
right um i'm curious to take their
response to this so on one hand cove
it's bad it's deadly people are dying
they're getting really sick um
it's been politicized the vaccine itself
has been politicized that is not fun um
on the other hand
this is where my question is coming like
we're not a
we're not a communist society we believe
in capitalism so if people want really
to live in the united states you have to
work generally speaking and if they want
to work they got to go outside and they
have to work with others and that risks
more coveted exposure right
so
those who can move to like adjust this
lifestyle i think have right there are
plenty of folks who had the means that
and those who wanted to were afraid of
covey they had and they could move they
have they moved to suburbs they moved to
places without door um less people more
outdoor space
but many have not or cannot um
so my question i really want to talk
about the policy ideas here given that
this i think you just kind of outlined
this is probably our new normal for the
next five years like maybe that's too
far but
it's not great several years several
yeah a number of years um if this
thing's gonna keep mutating and we all
keep
getting sick
what are the policy ideas i have a
couple but what what do you do if you're
in charge to navigate this because i
think what we're doing now is
unsustainable where it's like
don't mask up no no mask up we gotta
freak out like people are like oh we're
coming back and we're not coming back
like i think i don't know i don't have
bigger policy ideas that
navigate this new normal
well i i heard one thing that was not
great which is that uh apparently there
are issues of confidence with the cdc
not just in the public
but um
in the government yeah but they don't
want to turn the cdc into a punching bag
and so you're looking at it being like
oh you know but unfortunately public
confidence has already been
shaken so if you make various
recommendations
it's uh you know it's tough as you're
describing it's like wait what did you
say what like what did you say last time
yeah um so the thing we have to
acknowledge is that people are human uh
people have limited uh ability to absorb
different messages and and guidance and
and the rest of it
uh and so we should set out some broad
principles around
uh who you are what your vulnerability
level is uh and take it from there
in my opinion
um
so
if you're a normal person
uh you should
expect that you know getting vaccinated
is a good idea and that if you're
vaccinated there'll be some risk
associated with certain activities now
if you're not a vulnerable population
that risk will probably not be um
[Music]
no uh anything you can't recover from i
will say i have friends and family
members who have had long covid um and
it is a beast oh man horrible yeah like
it's it's terrible and they will recover
i most people know i had coveted and so
i recovered fully there was a period
when i was short of breath afterwards
when i was like oh this had better go
away
and then it did go away and i was very
very thankful
but you know i i know people who've
still been struggling with it
um i attended a memorial service of uh
someone's mother who died of
breakthrough covet i mean that was
freaking terrible and there are times i
look at my mom who's in her 70s i'm just
like well i mean she's been vaccinated
but you don't want
you know anything to break through
um
so you want to be accepting of the
limitations and fallibility of humans
and then lay out a number of things that
can be done that could genuinely
mitigate
the the harm so if if you are
in a particular environment i'll give an
example i went to a dave chappelle show
the other day
concert and then they tested the heck
out of us on the way in um and i thought
that was fine you know and then anyone
who was in there literally got a test
and you stood there for 10 minutes while
they gave you the result and be like
negative and so then you so then you
were with a bunch of people where you
had a fairly high confidence level that
they were
all negative um i think that's a fine
type of ongoing precaution right
um and then there's that
accepted level of risk that we all
probably need to start accepting is that
kova is a thing but we're not going to
sit at home all day so we're still going
to go to sporting events so to go to
concerts and restaurants and
um that should be the public policy
guidance it's like look there is risk
but you you can't eliminate the risk you
can mitigate it you can do various
things and so that that should be the
guidance
[Music]
you